hey everybody and welcome back to
beautiful Oslo
at least hopefully at some point in the
future this is gonna be as nice as the
real city for now it's just roads on an
overlay now and I have to give a warning
just as I said in the last episode this
episode will be exclusively me placing
roads over and overlay the goal of today
is basically to get all of the roads
almost all of the roads within the Outer
Ring of the city into this game here
which means that in the next episode we
can just start zoning stuff and then a
believable copy of Oslo should hopefully
start appearing as all of the right
buildings get into the right places
everything won't be quite exact but the
most important part is to get the roads
into the same places and that's what
we'll be doing today and because I'm
trying to do all that hard work in one
episode it isn't going to be the most
interesting time-lapse so I'll try to
use this time to actually talk about
some slightly more productive things and
expand a little bit on some of the stuff
that I've said in the last video and
reply to some comments as well because
to be very honest you guys absolutely
blew me away
in the last episode with the amount of
attention that this thing has been
getting and there were so many questions
and interesting points raised in the
comments that I would kind of like to
come back to that and use that as a way
to hopefully still make this video a
little bit more interesting so with that
said let's get into the time-lapse
alright so I'm starting with the centre
of the city here and as one of my first
things that I don't say about this is
don't fret if I don't get in every
single Road there are definitely a few
roads that have mists even though I was
checking the overlay and sort of
checking Google Maps every once in a
while as well to make sure that I get
all the right roads into the right
places there are definitely some roads
that I missed at this point which I know
now because I've already started
recording the next episode and there's a
lot that I have to get back to so don't
fret too much if I'm missing out on some
stuff but that said if there is anything
you noticed that I'm doing wrong or
emplacing the wrong road somewhere also
don't forget to say that because there's
definitely some stuff that I might
here in there just for the last episode
for instance I got this between this
steam message from someone that there
was this exact place where I was putting
the tram on the wrong block and it stuff
like that which I might definitely
quickly miss out but people who actually
live in Oslo which are a surprising
amount of my subscribers and never
actually imagined that so many people
that are subscribed to me our from Oslo
or know the area that well but there's
definitely a lot of stuff that I might
miss especially since unfortunately I've
never been here yet but yeah in general
there was just a lot of really amazing
feedback in the last episode although I
also have to say I think there were a
lot of expectations which is just way
too high I don't think this is gonna be
a project anywhere near on the scale of
say our city or my earlier Dutch city
which is already really old and kind of
outdated at this point and it's
definitely not going to be on the scale
of some of the amazing detailing
youtubers on YouTube right now which
there are way too many to name but I
don't think it's anywhere near that
level which you see alone in this game
the focus here is really to make a
believable copy of Oslo and it's on
quite a short timeframe and it doesn't
have a focus on detailing or making this
game look as pretty as possible but it
should really just be a way to create a
realistic believable simulation of Oslo
so keep that in mind that this series
was actually never really the the main
product here I honestly at the beginning
never even thought that I would make a
video series out of this this is just
kind of a byproduct that sort of helped
sort of helps raise awareness for the
project but it's it's not really the
focus here so the it was amazing to see
so many positive comments on the last
video but I have to say please curb your
expectations because it's it's probably
not gonna be as amazing as you think it
is there were also a bunch of other
questions which I just kind of wonder it
gets to doing a bit of a Q&A in this
video and reply to some of the comments
even though most of these I've also
replied to in the last video which is
always a great feature of
it's always something that only that
person and maybe just a few other people
will see but the majority of viewers
always kind of miss out on these things
so I want to address them in this video
as well and one of the first things that
I wanted to talk about is I got some
questions from people asking how long
this whole video takes how long the last
episode took since it was about half an
hour long but it's a time-lapse
obviously so there's a slight difference
there and basically I always speed up my
videos twelve times from the gameplay
speed partly because I think that's a
nice balance between being fast enough
to see the progress happening on screen
while at the same time not being so fast
that you don't see anything and it's
also the easiest speed to make time
lapses in Sony Vegas with so just about
a perfect speed which means that an half
an hour video like the last episode but
also this episode almost takes about six
hours to do since its bed up twelve
times so yeah that was quite a bit of
time put it into that and usually I
speed up all of my videos twelve times
so you can pretty much say that that
goes in every case may be for a few
exceptions or speed it up a little bit
less to maybe make something easier to
watch when I'm moving around the camera
a lot or something like that but you can
pretty much well always go for about
twelve times I think that's just about
the right speed I know there's
definitely some people who think that
the camera moves around a little bit too
much and usually I try to also counter
that by trying to move the camera as
little as I can I think that definitely
makes a huge difference and if you want
to make time lapses like this then
definitely try and keep the camera as
still as possible but in this case I
honestly didn't do that as much because
I rather focused on trying to make the
layouts as accurate as I could so yeah
that's one thing about these videos
another is I got a lot of comments and I
didn't really expect this about custom
assets and maybe the possibility that I
should ask the viewers to add custom
assets or slow
which is interesting because that's
never really gone through my mind before
I've talked with the people who
contacted me about this if there was
anybody on their team who could make
assets or if there was any other way to
add custom assets into this since it
would definitely greatly help for some
parts of the city and while they're sort
of internally looking at it I never
really thought of the fact that I might
be able to ask hewers about this but on
the same on the same hand like I don't
really want to do this since this
timeframe is really really short there's
only about two weeks from start to
finish in which I'm working on this and
I already started working on this a few
days before I released the first episode
so it's a really short timeframe to
expect something from other people and
to be honest it's not exactly the focus
of this either so what I want to say is
if you really want to try this and you
really want to make an essay from
something anything in Oslo then by all
means go ahead but I'm not asking for it
specifically I would love to see it but
keep in mind that the timeframe on this
is so short that honestly I might not
even use the asset and make sure that at
least it's something that any everybody
can make use of which to be honest I
think there are definitely some things
like then Oslo I think it's surprising
that even in city skylines it's kind of
the little brother of some of the other
Scandinavian capitals since there really
hasn't been much from Norway in general
on the workshop and there are no
buildings whatsoever from Oslo on the
workshop even though there are some
really interesting buildings that I
think could be used in any kind of
European City there is the the beautiful
signature Opera House on the water next
to the bar code project which the bar
code project itself has some very sort
of international modern or I should say
contemporary architectures that could be
used in any kind of city and the the
main Church of Oslo is also quite a nice
European Church so there are definitely
some signature buildings which could
vary
work in any case I I'm just a little bit
too afraid to actually ask people to
make these things because it's all so
tight etc but yeah if you really want to
do it then by all means I'm definitely
not gonna stop anybody but at the same
time I definitely don't wanna ask it of
anybody I do I think this relates quite
well to another question that I got as
well which is to what extent I'll be
going into detailing this city so what
level of detailing I'll really be making
Oslo in and the question was sort of
expanded upon by asking about train
routes bus routes maybe even zoning and
naming zones of the city accurately and
adding special services like fire
stations in hospitals etc I think a lot
of these things are limited by the game
engine itself for example I think when I
reply to it I mentioned the the fire
stations police stations etc which is a
super difficult issue because it's it's
such a complicated bureaucracy in real
life and in game it's just a building
with a certain certain spread of its
services which is kind of weird and not
exactly translates really well into the
game so when it comes to services like
fire stations etc it's all going to be a
little bit random and I really just want
to focus on making it gameplay wise
accurate so making sure that we have
enough coverage of fire stations police
stations to make sure that there's not
going to be any in increased crime or
fires all throughout the city which is
probably gonna result in an extra amount
of fire stations even if I'm trying to
get the fire stations with really really
good stats that makes sure that you
don't need to put as many as a real game
in but yeah it's not gonna be entirely
realistic it's really just gonna be
focused on the game
when it comes to bus routes and trains
and trams that sort of thing I've
actually got some apps and info on the
public transportation so this should be
covered as well as possible although the
focus will be on recreating certain
lines and other
it won't be as important but especially
the bus routes since they just kind of
used the same roads that are already
there should be about accurate and the
tram and the metro lines in the Train
will all be recreated as well so that
should eventually be fine and when it
comes to the zoning things
there's also another interesting issue
going on because one of the interesting
things that I think I mentioned in the
last episode as well that the streams
will want to look at when they're trying
to look at issues of urban development
using this map is that they want to look
at issues of properties so where are the
properties where can we build and how
can we sort of develop an area from that
which means that the idea was to use
districts as a way of marketing
properties which means that you do get a
bit of a clash since I'm naming and
using districts in certain areas to make
sure that we get certain themed
buildings but at the same time there are
also areas where I'll be using zones
rather than using them to do that use
them to market areas and this will be
focused on these newer areas which are
going to be developed into something
completely different like okay where
this is gonna be an issue so yeah I
would say partly zoning things and
getting accurate names will be partly
part of the map kind of like I've named
the central area just the the central
part of the state of the city and like
I've named the Central Station area but
it's not going to be everywhere and it's
not going to be on a super small scale
just because as great as the districts
are they also have to kind of fill in a
different use than just creating certain
neighborhoods and giving them a name
besides I guess there's also the time
consideration for myself since I'm doing
all of this on a very tight timeframe
and I mean I've got other things to do
as well I'm still University students I
have to go to class do my everything I'm
working on some parka tech stuff in the
background this was a place where I
never expected to say that but it's
something that I have to keep
mind so I don't have that much time to
spend on this and if I'm gonna spend
time on something it better be the most
important parts of making this map so
before districts and getting accurate
districts and giving them a nice name
I think I should definitely focus on
recreating the roads and buildings as
accurately as possible and making the
city look believable rather than just
getting some nice names in here because
it's slightly more fun to look at it
that way
so yeah to some extent I'll do that kind
of thing but it'll largely be very
undetailed you can pretty much assume
that let me actually see at what point
I'm actually working on the city here
we're about halfway down the episode and
I think also about halfway into all of
the roads that are placing you might
notice that I was using some slightly
different roads here and there one of
the things which I honestly kind of
struggle with in city skylines is that
the roads are insanely wide I think
their work all rights for importance
arterial roads or stuff like that but
when you get to these really small
neighborhoods I think the regular
two-box wide roads are slightly too wide
I have never really heard anybody like
I've heard some people talk about this
issue but I've never heard that much
conversation about it for but for me
it's one of the main issues of this game
it's it fits an American city and it
might fit some American suburbs but I
think in a lot of cases these two box
wide roads are just slightly too wide
for the on average much more narrow
European roads and sometimes I'm kind of
using a solution in the very narrow road
the road that's only one tile wide but I
think that's that's even slightly too
narrow so there's a little bit of a
challenge there so sometimes when a road
looks really small or when some roads
are really close together I'll be using
the one tile road but most of the times
I'm using the neighborhood / District
Road I'm not entirely sure what the name
is but it's the one with the slightly
lighter asphalt and it doesn't have the
white stripes on the middle the marking
so it
looks a little bit more like a regular
neighborhood road than the road with the
white stripes on it which I think works
pretty much all right it's not entirely
accurate and maybe the materials aren't
exactly right I also might want to look
into the color of the roads a little bit
I think the black asphalt is a little
bit too dark
considering that from what I've seen of
the roads and also they're slightly more
light but that's something that we can
always get back to later it's not too
difficult to change that sort of thing
there are also some challenges like that
tram roundabouts just now which is
something that is always quite difficult
having these tram tracks go alright
because in real life they kind of just
go wherever and they have some like
complex relations with the roads which
are really really difficult to recreate
in city skylines sometimes I'm using the
four-lane Avenue Road with the tram in
the middle and sometimes I'm using a
separate trem rail and then putting
one-way roads on both sides it really
kind of depends on what works best but
there are definitely especially around
the intersections some concessions that
I had to make for gameplay reasons and I
think that you especially noticed that
in this episode there are a lot of
intersections where if you look at them
on Google Maps they are a lot more
intricate than the way that I'm building
them in the game here and that's just
because sometimes it's completely
impossible to recreate these
intersections unfortunately there are
lots of intersections where different
roads come really close together to the
point where even if you use move it or
Road enter key to make these roads come
this close together in city skylines
you'll just get these weird bugs or
glitches where the asphalt disappears
and the grass comes through the road
when the roads are too close together so
they're just some parts where I have to
really just kind of bend the game a
little bit and get as close to real life
as I can but it's it's rarely actually
perfect right now this is also quite
interesting getting into the water
system here one of the Oh God I'm gonna
totally butcher this name again but like
you've got the married alpha net which
is like the lake at the north of the
city we
which is in real life in the place where
the city gannets gets its water so in
the game that's also something which I
wanted to do obviously the water pipes
aren't gonna be entirely realistic
because in general I'm kind of glad that
this game doesn't have a realistic water
system that would be an absolute hell to
hook up all the houses with but the
water is coming from the same place and
when we get to places like garbage the
garbage will definitely want to go to
similar places as well to create some
some detailed similarities between the
Oslo map and Oslo in real life it's
nothing really big but I think it's
something interesting to keep in mind
when you're doing the recreation and now
we're getting really close to the center
of the city which by the way is what
I'll be working on in the next episode I
guess I can already kinda spoil that so
I wanted to slightly get into a bit more
detail and why I'm making all of these
crazy roundabouts about here because
next episode I'll be working on this
area and adding some buildings in here
which should make it look as close at
least in composition to the real-life
counterpart as I can make it I also
decided to experiment a little bit with
the city center here so you might notice
that I'm already placing down some
buildings and stuff here but the the
majority of this will really just come
in the next episode so yeah I'm sorry
you're gonna have to wait for that one
also making the roundabouts is just one
of those intersection things which is
really difficult to get right in this
game and I definitely had to make some
concessions on as well because basically
just about the smallest roundabouts that
you can make in the game that still
looks good with a two-lane road which is
what I've been using for the roundabouts
even if the roundabouts in real life are
one way because or one lane just because
it makes the roundabouts a little bit
more wide and look a little bit more
like their real-life counterparts but
yeah the problem is the smallest
roundabouts that you can make and still
look good is a runabout made up of two
tiles curves so you've got a curve that
basically it has like a 2 by 2 floor
heights or
I don't know how to exactly say that but
yeah it's basically around about that's
about four tiles wide four tiles tall
and a pretty big circle and there's
nothing that's really smaller and works
out alright but many of the roundabouts
in the actual city are way smaller than
these it's just another limitation we're
making them smaller like then this would
be really impractical and difficult to
do so a lot of the roundabouts will be 2
tiles by 2 tiles curves so that's
something to kind of keep in mind as
well roundabouts is something which I
wish this game did better than it does
because it's never really been
implemented in this game and the only
way that you can make roundabouts right
now is to just get one-way roads and put
them in a roundabout shape but there's
no actual standard roundabout
intersection which is I think it's a
little bit of a shame I really feel as
though this game is built more on an
American Way of building cities even if
it's from Finland
it really feels that way with the lack
of roundabouts the wide road it's the
focus on grid style cities which are
definitely the easiest to do in this
game and the fact that even the European
buildings are struggling with making
corners obviously it's the easier way
and much more feasible way to make a
game like this as well but it's
something which makes making recreations
of European cities quite a bit harder
than taking an American city layout but
hey I guess no game is gonna be perfect
and I definitely don't want to vent
about this game because truth be told
what I was kind of realizing is that
before city skylines there wasn't really
a game in which you could have a project
like this surely there were ways of
simulating cities on the same level but
there was never a a professional popular
game with this amount of detail and this
ability to just completely recreate
real-life places and make them actually
look realistic on a large scale no way
to do that kind of thing in any of the
SimCity games so honestly that's still
really cool I think and it's still one
of the reasons why I like this game so
much it's a game in which you can
actually just take your city fantasies
or
a real existing city and just built them
to an astonishing degree even if it's
buggy sometimes and if assets and mods
weight it down a lot and if you actually
want to get some decent performance as
well you really have to keep everything
toned down quite a bit it's still a
really awesome thing to do and something
which honestly years ago I wouldn't even
be thinking of it being able to do so
yeah props with that I hope that at
least evens up my Karma after always
complaining that games anyway I think
there is this one thing which I haven't
talked about yet and that is how I did
the overlay and the height map and I
should definitely link down some things
in its description because I got a lot
of questions if I wanted to make a
tutorial about how I make this map but
to be honest I don't think I should
because there are already really good
videos out on YouTube that teach you how
to make a height map and how to make
this kind of overlay so I definitely
recommend that and I'll link something
down in the description the only thing
that I recommend doing differently is I
think I remember when a lot of channels
make the overlay they don't make it
transparent the way that I've been doing
here or they just get a overlay straight
from a picture and just put it on the
city and like try to sink it into the
ground
I think this way of doing an overlay is
slightly more handy since you can see
the roads but you can also still see
everything else like even though you see
the overlay it doesn't change the look
of the city that much and it's
transparent enough to be able to see
what you're building through it so I
like this way of doing the overlay most
its visible but it's not super intrusive
to how the city looks and I just my
personal preference you can obviously
make these overlays whatever way you
want to but if you want to make it the
way that I've been doing it's basically
I just removed all of the things all of
the colors that I didn't want in
paint.net with a colored 2-alpha
plug-in which there are many of them
which you can find on the Internet and
actually maybe I'll try to link down
something if I can find something but
I'm not sure where I got mine in the end
and then made sure that the whole image
is just about 25% visible so it's more
transparent than it is actually visible
which make sure that you can actually
see through the overlay it's not
something which I quite like but that
aside there are plenty of really great
tutorials on YouTube showing you how to
make these kinds of things and I think
there's quite a large community that's
interested in recreating cities which I
could definitely also tell from the
amount of requests that I've been
getting to try and recreate another city
and I have to be honest I don't really
usually do recreations unless there's
like a special reason to do so
but I also kind of have to say that
there's this really cool series by
Chrome's McGee on YouTube which you
should definitely check out a lot of his
other videos are really amazing too but
he's got a project which he's making
Rotterdam in and I study in Rotterdam I
live really close to the city so I love
that place and I know pretty much every
part of it and it's really cool to
actually see how awesome it is to see a
city that you're so used to being
recreated in city skylines and the only
problem is that his Rotterdam projects
has kind of fallen silence a little bit
I've talked about this with him for a
bit as well and there's some technical
issues with the save but maybe maybe
just maybe and I might have to add
another maybe two there just to make
that a little bit more realistic just
maybe I might pick that up at some point
in the future because if that thing is
left hanging and I've got enough spare
time on my hands I would love to get a
little bit more interested in because
it's something which I've always kind of
wanted to do I just never thought that
it would be feasible and here comes
crumbs and he just makes a super
accurate amazing recreation of a part of
Rotterdam so that's pretty motivating
actually it's something which maybe I'll
get into at some point in the future but
look I don't wanna make any promises
because like I said in the last episode
have been starting way to many things
and I really need to start finishing
things as well so after this my focus is
really gonna be on getting back to some
of my older cities making not cities or
in general coming back and making more
episodes of Jaeger horn Armour city and
Favara to finish those things because
they're really kind of going toward the
end and being almost finished but not
quite and that's kind of a shame those
things really need to be released at
some points so yeah I hope to get back
to those things I'm back in the
Netherlands now so I should have a
little bit more time it's just some
things have been coming up that I've
been keeping me from getting to them so
far and one of those things is this
project by the way if you're still here
and you're still watching the video I
have to give huge props to you because
this must have been tremendously boring
to watch I know I got quite a few
comments in the last video of people
saying that they were actually
interested in me
placing roads over an overlay I I guess
that's fair I'm not gonna bash on what
everybody is interested in better I I
know this is probably quite a bit more
boring than most city skylines series
should be so let's get into the the
center of the city in the next episode
things should be heading toward slightly
more detail and more actual buildings in
the next episode but yeah I really have
to commend your your stamina in video
watching to actually make it up to this
point it was definitely quite difficult
for me at some points to keep placing
roads for hours on end
big thanks also to some of the amazing
music creators which have definitely
been able to pull me through this thing
but just listening to music all day
which is an interesting thing actually
because when you're recording a time
lapse you're not just recording the time
lapse usually people are doing something
else in the background as well which I
never really know what other people are
doing for me I like to listen to music
sometimes hope into discord call and
during the city during this city build
I've also listened a lot to 99%
invisible which is by far my favorite
podcast ever they recently actually
released some episodes about urban
design in Amsterdam looking at the
Baumer area specifically which was
really cool to listen to while building
this city
I know for a lot of people I don't
really know what they're doing while
they're recording these kinds of time
lapses but I definitely think it's
something which is you know it takes a
lot of time but it doesn't take your
attention as much as just to the point
where you're doing a very similar thing
the whole time so for me I just really
want to do something in the background
listen to something else or talk with
some people whatever it is do something
so I'm actually secretly kind of
interested in what other people are
doing like what are you doing when
you're doing this this sort of thing and
this is by no means a way to just
shoehorn in some viewer interactivity in
my video it's just something that I just
kind of figured like what do you do
while you're playing City skylines even
if you're you're just filming your own
city for fun do you just listen to the
game soundtrack or have some music in
the but in the background or listen to
some podcasts it's kind of interesting
to see what people are doing with these
kinds of games especially since it's a
little bit more of a therapeutic
experience it doesn't take your whole
attention kind of like shooter games or
strategy games but it's just kind of
something that you're doing in a sort of
relaxed state in the background so it's
I think a whole other kind of process
and a whole other motivation to play a
video game in general
in any case as you might be able to see
I'm almost hanging to at the end of this
time-lapse just finishing a few roads on
this side of the city but that's really
it
so I'd like to thank you guys for
watching big props if you made it until
this far and I hope to see you guys in
the next video in which I'll be getting
to the center of the city bye guys
[Music]